they watch is headed to theaters a week
from Friday it's sexy irreverent and
wait until you see all the kisses what
about kissing Zac Efron Zac have soft
lips yeah okay all right but you got to
say with with like you know wait in
divorce Zac Efron had some soft lips
guys who kissed better me being serious
obviously the Rob no she was a better
kisser for sure
Roy but but it was funnier to look up
and see a face looking up and seeing
Alexandra's face actually had Zac a
little smitten
during our press day he was tweeting
pictures of the two of them with quote
Pete those eyes what is it like looking
in her eyes it's crazy
just just look into the camera you see
like there's it's a different blue you
haven't seen before it's like they have
superpowers your own your eyes have
superpowers strangely enough they
haven't been super powdery there were
also long looks and kisses between
Dwayne and he'll Phoenicia Dara is
Dwayne being asked what it's what might
his kiss with I'll finish beside
thank you uh yeah I'd like to hear that
answer Duane she said tell me Duane what
was it like I want you to imagine your
favorite milkshake okay I want you to
add the greatest thing you've ever
tasted mix it all up and that's what
it's like kissing me I mean this room
huh I'm giving up kidding of course
but the rock has to feel good about
himself he had just flown in from the
set of what might be another blockbuster
rampage based on the 80s video game how
are you balancing all this crazy it's
crazy but but it's but it's good I think
the number one thing that I need get the
family clothes where I go they go that
becomes my anchor and then I go to work
you know that Baywatch team really has
become close but um here's the funny
thing Nancy Alexander said it wasn't
that romantic kissing Zach because there
was too much chlorine in the water Wow I
don't have the problem when I'm kissing
my wife in high school well I don't
think most women with a color even
bothered them if they were this is a
capper yeah
[Music]